hồi sinh gia tộc
phạm thoại comeback gây choáng với giao diện lạ hoắc
giới điệu mộ ngã ngửa đồng loạt truy lùng chiếc kính vai
tổng tài
cú trở lại của Phạm thoại thật sự khiến TikTok dậy sóng
giao loạt ồn ào
từng khiến nhiều người nghĩ rằng
anh chàng sẽ rút khỏi đường đua
phạm thoại bất ngờ xuất hiện
trở lại với một hình ảnh hoàn toàn khác
không còn màu mè
không ồn ào
mà là một giao diện điềm đạm lạnh và có phần soái hơn hẳn
điều khiến cộng đồng mạng chú ý không chỉ là thần thái
mà còn là chiếc kính không viền
dáng mảnh phối Kim loại sáng
đeo lên là tổng thể Nam TikToker thay đổi hoàn toàn vay
từ TikToker
quay mặt sang cảm giác tổng tài bước Ra từ phòng họp
netizen soi kỹ còn bảo
chính chiếc kính này làm gương mặt trông sắc nét hơn
ánh mắt có chiều sâu và tạo cảm giác vừa Nam
tính vừa cấm dục
chỉ sau vài giờ
nhiều người bắt đầu hỏi nhau
chiếc kính phạm thoại đeo là của hãng nào
form gì vì nhìn thì đơn giản nhưng lên mặt lại cuốn bất ngờ
có thể nói lần comeback này giống như một màn
reset nhân vật
và nếu đây chỉ mới là màn chào sân
thì netizen vẫn đang chờ xem
thoại sẽ còn mang tới bao nhiêu phiên bản mới nữa Cho hành
trình tiếp Theo